please
it's so nice to meet you it's so funny i
think there are some serious parallels
here oh boy yeah yeah i think i mean god
knows if we have time
well let's see how old were you when you
did my girl and was that
like the beginning or that was so
when i so that was my first
film right um
you know i think i was i was put in like
you know
uh carson perry scott ads i was put in
commercials and things since i was a
baby i was 10 months old when i did my
first print ad so yeah no chance to be a
person yet at all
right yeah
and then is it true that you took a
different type of job though well so my
entry level position out of college this
is when i was definitely definitely done
with show business i was not um you know
i was over it and um and so
yeah i
was a fact checker for the zagat food
guides i don't know if anybody even
remember
of course we do
there was not one
okay first of all i feel like it was the
first way that we could all become
foodies yeah yeah it's true what was it
like working there it that now it is a
survey so really the happiest people
working there were the mathematicians
because we didn't get to do the eating
it was all of the public eating and they
would just tell us what they thought was
good so i was a fact checker i was in a
windowless room with two other people um
uh and um and we made the best of it but
we had to call cold call restaurants and
properties and just go through a
15-minute questionnaire when they were
like at their busiest it was what was in
the questionnaire can you remember a
question um oh gosh what's your
signature dish
um where are you located what are the
cross streets if it's new york
[Laughter]
[Music]